the turtle war franchise is the series
the england-based developer the creative
assembly is best known for the studio
has crafted a franchise that has become
a crown jewel in this strategy genre
delivering a diverse range of titles
that have earned a claim from fans and
critics alike
across this video i'm going to be
delving into the history of total war on
pc while i won't be going into too much
detail about the various spin-offs on
mobile titles i'll hopefully be sharing
some interesting stories about the
game's development and maybe even
tickling your historical nostalgia bone
along the way with all that being said
let's get into the history of total war
[Music]
back before they became champions of
strategy the creative assembly had much
humbler beginnings the company was
founded in 1987 by tim ansell who
remained as the sole employee until 1989
and the first job he took on was to port
amiga and atari sd games the dos system
between 1993 and 1994 the creative
assembly started slowly expanding and
began working with electronic arts
developing games like fifa international
soccer and rugby world cup for dos under
the ea sports label but in 1996 it
became clear that the company needed to
expand further and a clear driving force
behind this was the hiring of michael
simpson simpson previously a microchip
designer came on board as the creative
director of the creative assembly and
his hiring was instrumental in the
creation and success of the total war
series
the success of the sports titles gave
creative assembly the capital the
opportunity and the backing from ea to
develop some more high-risk titles their
first being shogun total war originally
shogun total war started life as an rpg
based on the ming dynasty chinese novel
journey to the west before evolving into
an rts focusing on the sengoku period of
japan the development of shogun total
war was led by simpson since it was
conceived as a potential b-tier rts game
development was handled by a secondary
team within the company and the game was
intended to capitalize on the popularity
of games like command and conquer with
the advancement of hardware tech there
was an increased use of 3d fx video
cards which allowed creative assembly to
move the game from 2d to 3d graphics
simpson was initially skeptical on the
use of 3d graphics given the large scope
of their game but was surprised when a
3d rendered battlefield turned out to
actually be feasible from this point
onwards the project grew from a b-tier
game into something much more
substantial the shift from a 2d to a 3d
battlefield fundamentally changed the
gameplay the team realized they had the
potential to push what could be done
with an rts title instead of being
forced into the traditional overhead
camera the idea was to move the player
into more the position of a general one
that had a raised vantage point where
they could survey the battlefield the
idea of this general also influenced the
decision to take a more historical
approach to the units and tactics of the
game at this stage the game was just
battle after battle with very little to
tie it all together this is when simpson
introduced the idea of having something
to make players care about the warfare
this thought led the creation of the
wider campaign map japan was chosen as
the location not only because it was
cool as hell but because the sengoku
period also allowed for the choice of
several factions that could have
realistically won the conflict it also
meant for an engaging and expansive
technology tree in the game reflecting
the period where the war's wage in japan
were rapidly changing due to the
introduction of gunpowder rifle and
cannon to maintain a high level of
historical accuracy creative assembly
approached stephen turnbull a military
historian specializing in samurai
warfare they also went as far as
implementing elements of sun tzu's the
art of war into the game's artificial
intelligence meaning the decisions being
made by the mpc factions were as
historically accurate as possible shogun
total war was a huge success selling
over 200 000 copies in the uk alone and
currently sitting at an 84 on metacritic
17 years later the game was praised for
rewarding players for using long-term
tactical thinking when the current
strategy genre was focused on instantly
gratifying battles as well as adding an
incredible layer of authenticity and
research to the game's feudal japanese
setting the start of a new series and
their new take on strategy was a
commercial and critical success for the
studio showing that they were to be
taken seriously in the genre and
allowing them to round out their first
total war release with the mongol
invasion expansion pack shogun total war
is so fondly remembered that it would
even receive a hd re-release on steam 15
years after it graced home pcs
not long after the success of shogun
creative assembly broke away from
electronic arts instead choosing to
partner with activision to publish and
distribute the second to all game
medieval total war was to be of a much
wider scope than previous shogun
spanning a much longer time period with
a much larger map consisting of the
entirety of medieval europe africa and
the middle east medieval also introduced
siege battles to the series which at
first received some criticism for the
difficult unit management during these
types of battles but would eventually
evolve into a fundamental gameplay
element for the rest of the franchise
again there was a huge focus on
historical accuracy with the year in
game closely reflecting the historical
state of each faction over that time the
factions varied from the byzantine
empire england hungary and the holy
roman empire as well as the golden horde
of the great mongol khans which even
showed up at the historically accurate
time creative assembly even researched
key historical figures of the period
including a vice and virtue system which
was designed to make in-game characters
behave like their real world
counterparts medieval's working titles
actually crusade a total war and the
development started only a few weeks
after shogun was released the game later
became medieval total war as the scale
and scope of the game increased beyond
that of just the crusades with the
addition of an updated engine the
battles were larger than ever troop
limits were increased to 10 000 and the
improved engine allowed army placement
on the campaign map to influence the
maps in which they would fight in the
battle phases if you started combat near
a river or cliff extra effort was made
to reflect that in your battle map the
wider scope improved gameplay much
larger roster of factions and units made
medieval total war an even bigger
success than its predecessor going on to
sell 1.5 million copies
the early roman empire would be the
setting for the third total war game
allowing players to lead one of the
three great roman houses of the time the
julia brutii or skippy eye the wider
factions such as britannia gold and
greece that occupy the rest of the
campaign map would remain locked until
you either destroyed them or completed a
campaign or if you were smart enough to
look how to edit the txt files in the
game's back end and unlock all the
factions like a naughty cheater which is
what i did before players could get
their hands on the game though versions
of it were used in two separate tv
programs decisive battles on the history
channel and the fantastic time
commanders on bbc two two teams would
take roles as generals and lieutenants
and reenact historical battles effort
was made to choose people with little
gaming experience to ensure their skill
with games would not influence the
victories the code for the core game and
the one used in shows were pretty much
the same with some tweaks for the tv
programs rome total war designer and
writer mike brunton said time commanders
did use rome code pretty much as is with
tweaks for different troop types and
camera controls due to the bbc rules
about product placement the show never
referenced the game engine used but
creative assembly were credited at the
end of each program
rome total war became one of the best
selling and highest review games of the
series it cemented itself as an all-time
favorite fans of the series even to this
day it currently stands at a 92
metacritic with some reviews back in
2004 calling it one of the best strategy
games of all time
it was the first total war game i played
and the game that made me fall in love
with the series i'm pretty sure without
it i would have failed all the history
exam questions i had about the roman
empire in march 2005 a few months after
the release of rome sega announced they
had sealed an acquisition with creative
assembly with sega buying all issued
shares and explaining that this move was
to strengthen sega europe's presence in
the european and north american markets
sega would then build the strategy brand
by publishing two expansion packs for
rome one focusing on the barbarian
nations of europe and the middle east
during the period of migration and the
other allowing wannabe generals to take
control of alexander the great after his
ascension to the macedonian throne in
336 bc
the sega acquisition would mark the end
of tim ansel's time in the company after
founding it nearly 17 years and 11
months prior having built the company
from a one-man operation porting dos
games to a titan of the strategy genre
to nearly 100 staff he said his
farewells
[Music]
medieval 2 was an indirect sequel to the
2002 medieval it kept the familiar
setting and factions but expanded on
them hugely one of medieval two's major
new additions was motion captured
battles previously units would have one
or two simplistic attack animations but
the new system allowed for more varied
and immersive combat complete with
parrying and finishing moves which were
also dependent on what weapon the
individual soldier was using those
soldiers would also appear more varied
rather than being clones of the same
couple of infantrymen the troops would
have individual faces and
characteristics and the in-game upgrades
such as new armor would change how a
model looked in battles adding leather
armor to a unit in the campaign map
would add it to the unit when you
started a battle medieval 2 stayed true
to the core gameplay of the previous
titles in the series but had to take
some small historical liberties for
example russia didn't exist as a unified
state during that period of history as
it was separated into various
principalities and fiefdoms a unified
spain also didn't exist until the end of
the game's timeline but for the sake of
accessibility and for the flow of
gameplay these were brought together
into solidified factions following a
pattern in the series medieval 2 was
well received by fans and critics alike
although some players did comment that
it wasn't as revolutionary to the
franchise as the games that preceded it
it was however reviewed by swedish
historian peter englerd who concluded
that the battles were amazingly similar
to depictions seen in early cop
engravings from the 1600s which surely
put a smile on the face of the
developers focusing on that historical
accuracy
before the release of empire mike
simpson stepped down from his studio
director role handing over the running
of the studio to tim heaton so he could
focus on making the games in a more
creative role empire total war was a new
swing at tried and true formula it had
the more modern time period of the 18th
century and with that came the
prominence of range and gunpowder
weapons which created a whole new
dynamic the combat in previous games had
a huge focus on melee between
rank-and-file soldiers whereas empire
had a much bigger focus on ranged combat
to think about it was also the first
total war game to include naval combat
giving admirals the opportunity to take
a fleet of up to 20 ships out to open
water
ships could be ordered to target
specific parts of enemy vessels with
different types of ammunition depending
on the strategy they wanted to employ
chain shot could top a mass and
immobilize ships and grapeshot could
wound soldiers creating the opportunity
to board and capture enemy vessels
empire also shipped with nine different
versions of boxer with one being an
international version and the other
eight sporting an in-game faction of the
country it was being sold in american
artwork shows american revolutionaries
english had the red coats and germany
had prussian flags in infantry empire
became the fastest selling total war
title even topping the british video
game charts this was the first time a pc
exclusive title had done so in over a
year and a half but while initial sales
were good the community reaction was
decidedly less positive as part of the
post-release support creative assembly
had many issues with gameplay and
artificial intelligence to address in an
attempt to communicate these issues with
the community mike simpson took to his
blog and stated the ai was the most
complex code he'd ever seen in a game
but one of the major issues was that the
lead battle ai programmer left the
project before the release of the game
so other programmers were given the
herculean task of understanding and
finishing three years worth of code it
took multiple updates across six months
for the game to reach the standard that
the creative assembly felt the game
should have originally launched with
napoleon total war shared a lot of
similarities with empire due to some
crossover in the game's time frame and a
lot of shared technology muskets rifle
cannon and cavalry was still the order
of the day but the core of the gameplay
would be following napoleon's military
career as well as allowing players to
play through historical battles like
napoleon's confrontation with wellington
at the battle of waterloo outside of
napoleon's story mode there was the
campaigns of the coalition allowing
players to play as the austrian british
prussian or russian empires the focus on
narrative and a singular character was
another new direction for the total war
series an extra effort was made to make
the map much more detailed than that of
empire in an attempt to reflect the
intensity of the time period this also
meant they shortened the in-game year's
turn time to just a couple of weeks
rather than previous games using seasons
or full years this was in order to give
players a sense of constant skirmishing
napoleon also sported a new physics
system for its real-time battles cannon
fire would leave craters and gouges in
the field when fired and gun powder can
accumulate in drawn out battles creating
clouds and affecting visibility
as with the battles in that time period
generals and commanders would put a lot
of thought into the environmental
factors they would face and their
thought process made it into the battles
too elevation had an increased effect on
munitions range and there was even a
chance for ranged weapons to misfire if
they were fighting in rain there were
mixed reviews when the game was released
some states in the creative assembly
have obviously learned some lessons from
the ai troubles from empire while others
called it a re-skinned empire that felt
more like an expansion pack than a brand
new game either way the discussion
didn't last long as the next game
arrived just a year later
total war shogun 2 was the return to
where it all started 11 years after the
original shogun the team revisited japan
in the 16th century many saw this game
as a return to form for the studio
citing that the re-simplification and
refinement of the decade-long formulas
created a purer total war experience
next to the previous shogun it was easy
to see how far the series and creative
assembly had come the game was a much
more intimate affair than previous
titles that had spanned continents and
most of the globe instead there were
nine clans to lead with an extra added
via dlc and while there were fewer
unique units than previous total war
games special effort was made to add
enough unique abilities the existing
ones that any strategy could still be
considered it also kept the inspiration
from sun tzu's the art of war that was
present in the original shogun the break
away from the character-driven napoleon
and more of a role-play rpg approach was
implemented with the warlords that you
would command in shogun these generals
would have their own unique abilities
and gain experience through battle and
administration allowing the player to
craft their own unique leader and tailor
them for different strategies as the
warlords are vying for power of the
shogunate the game implements a unique
event known as realm divide if the
player captures enough territories or
rules over kyoto one by one the rest of
the clans will declare war on the player
faction creating a new balance of power
and control in a tug-of-war loss and
game mechanic that extends to the end
game and creates new game challenges the
next game would also have creative
assembly revisiting familiar ground and
bringing something new to it
[Music]
since the first total war players had
become used to ordering their droves of
infantry and cavalry sending virtual
legions into battle in a somewhat
detached fashion with total war roam 2
creative assembly wanted to inject some
more humanity into the armies under your
command and add a little more gravitas
to the combat at the same time i have
heard it said that greeks like a good
argument
they also like good food good wine
talking learning and generally being
civilized
that's very nice but war is not a nice
business
why are they here
[Applause]
one of the most brutal yet humanizing
additions was the reactions that troops
would have as their comrades died around
them ballista bolts would fly through
units and arrows rained down upon them
all the while infantry would look around
them in horror as morale dropped naval
combat was also tweaked to be much more
useful in total war room 2. it was now
possible to have hybrid battles on land
and sea allowing for many more strategic
options for generals and admirals alike
ship to ship combat could still take
place but you could also load vessels
with legionnaires and use them to
assault a city's docks while your land
units reached the gates this additional
breadth to battle and the depth in
strategic options was important to the
growth of the total wars gameplay
uniqueness was a huge focus in the
development of total war room 2. with
vast cultural differences between
factions it was important each faction
played in a distinct way some factions
focused on conquest and waging wars
barbarians while others focused on
diplomacy and trade fighting with more
stoicism and precision on the
battlefield lead unit designer jack
lusted stated the rebel nations of the
original rome total war were there to
represent minor nations but turtle war
rome 2 opted to introduce dozens of
these minor nations to have them play a
more active part which resulted in the
game having one of the largest rosters
in the series so far 117 factions with
over 500 different units the 8th total
war game would release in 2013 to some
technical controversy with many players
plagued with crashes texture problems
failures to launch poor game performance
and consistent reports of broken
artificial intelligence an anonymous
developer from another studio even took
to the forums blaming sega for the state
of the game on its release and sharing
feelings that the game had
comprehensively failed to be tested hot
fixes were being implemented as quickly
as possible as more and more players
reported issues mike simpson eventually
issued an apology alongside a statement
from the studio promising to further
patch the game at the time two percent
of players were reporting issues but the
message was clear that was two percent
too many
while it was a frustrating time for
hopeful roman emperors the silver lining
was that these issues would help shape
the way total war games were treated and
released in the future going forward the
studio would have a bigger focus on
player feedback and community dialogue
hoping to avoid another bungled launch
of this kind for their newer games even
amidst all the issues total war room 2
was the biggest commercial success for
the studio yet having more sales and
concurrent players than any other total
war game to date and its popularity was
so intense that 19 pieces of campaign
culture and faction packs were released
the most recent being empire divided one
that launched as recently as november
2017.
[Music]
total water tiller took on a much more
apocalyptic flavour being referred to as
more of a survival strategy game than
its preceding titles with the constant
threat of hordes the arrival of a mini
ice age cities in flames and scorched
earth commanders and factions had to
think fast and adapt quickly to deal
with unexpected scenarios
attila was another twist in the total
war formula strategies that you've
learned across the previous titles
didn't always work as the hordes
descended across europe instead of
slowly expanding and having safe
settlements deep in their territory
players were forced to abandon
settlements for a quick increase in
treasury and consolidate their forces as
factions struggle for food factions
could abandon cities and become nomadic
having the ability to pick the land
clean as they conquered even burning and
looting the cities and lands around them
making them inhospitable and dead for
the settlers that followed volcanic
activity a mini ice aged fire ravaging
cities and barbarians ascending from a
cold north made attila a much more
brutal and punishing game with some
players and critics even criticizing it
for its increased difficulty but attila
was a much more dynamic campaign
especially when playing as the hun
himself the pace and brutality of the
game encourages the player to move and
adapt to new situations exploring the
map for more fruitful lands instead of
setting up a reliable home province
surrounding a capital which makes sense
since given the time period your faction
was on a knife's edge
the newfound angle of survival strategy
was followed by another radical change
[Music]
while previously grounded in real world
history total war warhammer was the
first to foray into the world of fantasy
in december of 2012 sega announced a new
partnership with games workshop to
produce games for the warhammer series
at the time creative assembly already
had five titles in development including
rome 2 and 2014's alien isolation so a
new warhammer series would be a long way
away however the game was leaked in
their book the art of total war a few
months prior to the official
announcement on april 22nd 2015. while
the annals of history had proven to be a
deep well of inspiration for the
developers behind total war they now had
a huge 32 year old franchise rich with
lore and stories to draw from but a huge
franchise like warhammer would also come
with legions of ravenous fans ready to
bear teeth if their beloved fictional
universe was mishandled at the time it
was announced i had been a total war fan
and a warhammer fan since my early teens
and while this was a game i had been
praying to the chaos gods for for so
many years even i was apprehensive about
how these franchises would merge
thankfully my fears were misplaced on
the 24th of may 2016 creative assembly
released their most ambitious total war
to date it was a lot of firsts it was
the first of a trilogy it was the first
total war to branch out of the history
books the first total war to be attached
to another major ip and the first hot
award to feature big daft dragons
zombies magic and gross demons while the
factions in the history-based total war
games shared some similarities each race
in warhammer is so distinct and unique
the developers and diners had to tap
into decades of law and models to ensure
they do their in-game depictions justice
same with the campaign map and the wider
world adaptations would have to be made
for the sake of gameplay while also
keeping true to the source material to
keep fans of both franchises happy
characters in generals were made to
stand out more by giving them unique
spells and abilities similar to how
they'd been treated in the tabletop game
the attention to detail was incredible
and having seen creative assemblies
warhammer room and the hundreds of books
used to tap into the law it's plain to
see that they've done their due
diligence while it released with
relatively few factions in comparison to
other total war games only four in the
core game at launch the races were so
different that it meant subsequent
playthroughs made for a much more
different experience than in any other
previous game consolidating a kingdom as
the empire was way different than wiring
your way across the old world as the
orcs being a new total war in a brand
new direction and being attached to a
much beloved ip the excitement was
electric for total warhammer launched
with its share of controversy
the warriors of chaos are one of the
most popular and prominent factions in
the warhammer franchise which may have
been a factor when it came to how the
community reacted to the announcement
that they'd be available as dlc they
were made available to buy at launch but
free for players who pre-ordered the
game and this decision was widely
criticized by fans of both total war and
warhammer a reaction that creative
assembly was disheartened by in an
attempt to remedy this they made the
faction free dlc for anyone who
purchased the game the week of its
release another case of a hiccup shaping
the company's approach their games this
reaction would help inform how creative
assembly would handle pre-orders and dlc
going forward total war warhammer was
always intended to be a trilogy with the
massive worlds of each game merging
together with the development of each
chapter in the series the titles would
stack on top of each other to create one
seamless and massive world and campaign
this became the mortal empire's campaign
with the october 2017 update however
total war warhammer 2 was focused on the
western new world and its centerpiece
the great vortex this time around there
was much more focus on a narrative
campaign than in previous titles with
the races of the skaven high elves dark
elves and lizard men having their own
unique storylines revolving around
seizing power from the great vortex the
combination of total war warhammer 1 and
2 created the largest total war
experience to date collectively titled
the mortal empires campaign it pulled
together the factions settlements spells
legendary lords and units into the
biggest map the franchise had ever seen
this collection of legendary lords and
factions only grew with the selection of
dlc and free lc that would follow the
release of the game some of which having
their own unique campaigns completely
separate from the struggles of the
vortex with the most interesting
addition in my opinion being that of the
vampire coast interesting because unlike
much of the other factions in the total
war warhammer titles there were no
miniatures to base the unit designs off
of so instead the designers at creative
assembly had to work with games workshop
to use lore snippets of stories and
lists from issues of white dwarf to
create heroes and units to flesh out
their new faction of crustacean riding
zombies and enchanted walking pirate
ships maybe the vampire coast was a
testing ground for this idea as some of
the factions making at the roster for
total war warhammer 3 have been built in
much the same way but between the second
and third entry between the warhammer
titles creative assembly would visit
both history and a different form of
fiction once more total war saga thrones
of britannia was the first game in
creative assembly shorter but more
focused style of campaigns instead of
encompassing a wide era of history the
game revolved around a much shorter time
period thrones of britannia made a much
more detailed britain than we were used
to seeing in historical titles with
players being able to take control of
vikings anglo-saxons as well as the
welsh and gaelic kingdoms to become king
of the isle during the 9th century
series director mike simpson said that
the point of the saga series was to put
a more defined geographical area under a
microscope and build a strong focus on
the culture of the factions lands and
time period this was reflected both in
the gameplay but also on a more micro
level with things like the design of the
ui featuring artwork and unit portraits
that strongly resemble art and
tapestries of the time some think that's
only really doable with a game that
focuses much more deeply on the history
and area that it's representing the game
also offered more courses for victory in
the campaign with conquest fame and
kingdom all culminating into an ultimate
victory but there were also smaller
changes to the gameplay that tied into
the setting for example when recruiting
units they would appear at low strength
and build up which was meant to mimic a
sense of mustering and the game played
more with unique events and branching
dilemmas that were often built around
authentic historical events of the time
period the game did a lot with smaller
elements like this and it felt like a
bed for feature experimentation that
could reappear in the mainline games as
well as being an interesting more
focused take on a smaller piece of
history it was exciting to see as the
more historically focused part of the
fanbase had been waiting a return to the
history books for a number of years the
next game however was an intriguing
blend of historical authenticity and
fictional fantasy
total war three kingdoms shone a
spotlight on the leaders and warlords of
china in the year 220 with a total war
game that was much more character driven
than we were used to seeing the core
inspiration of the game came from the
three kingdoms period of china as well
as the 14th century novelization of the
time period romance of the three
kingdoms the split of two flavors of the
era created two versions of the game the
records version gave players a much more
classical and grounded version of total
war with characters accompanied by
bodyguards the romance version however
played to the larger than life
characters from the novel allowing
one-on-one duels as well as incredible
feats of combat prowess and special
skills the audio of the day however was
still focused on the characters of the
game with more emphasis given to
character development customization and
satisfaction within your faction lords
and generals could create bonds or
rivalries which would affect their
performance in combat if they were
fighting against their sworn enemy or
buffing the morale if they were fighting
side by side with a friend this would
create a lot of interesting moments as
you manage your faction to a higher
degree than just chess pieces on a board
if two characters were bonded and you
executed one of the pair then players
would have to deal with those
repercussions as the campaign progressed
the type of character would also dictate
what units you were able to field in
battle as each champion strategist
vanguard commander or sentinel would be
able to recruit different units and give
those units different advantages for
example strategists were able to field
better range units and vanguards were
best suited to lead the cavalry portion
of your army the emphasis on character
development and their connected gameplay
mechanics as well as building new story
elements proved to be a hit with players
and romance mode was praised for
bringing in some of the action scene in
warhammer titles while also balancing it
with historical authenticity and setting
for this total war 3 kingdoms was able
to set a series record for the most
concurrent players during its week of
release and was at the time the
franchise's fastest selling title
selling a million copies within a week
of its release after toying with pure
history complete fiction and a blend of
both creative assembly's next game to
follow the three kingdoms would bring in
a little bit of the mythological to the
world of total war total war saga troy
is so far the title that has gone
furthest back in history set in the
bronze age of the 13th century bc which
puts it around 900 to a thousand years
before the setting of total war rome
as the name suggests the game is set
during the trojan war but also covers
the surrounding aegean yet it still
retains more of the focused geographical
and cultural scope that the saga series
is built around it's the ancient culture
and subsequent mythology that surrounds
this time period that makes for the
game's unique selling point due to the
lack of historical records and sources
from the location and time period the
design team at creative assembly sophia
instead used the ancient greek epic poem
the iliad to build their world but
instead of ignoring the mythical
elements of the work they instead lent
into creating what was described as the
truth behind the myth with this their
aim was to try and provide historically
authentic explanations behind myths and
legends tying them together with stories
and legends with a modern view for
example centaurs were riders that held
close tied to their horses and rode
without a saddle creating a silhouette
of one form rather than actually being
the half-man half horse that the myth
portrays them as as the game grew
however we saw the release of the mythos
dlc and the ways to play the game grew
to three one being a historical version
of the campaign similar to what the
records mo did for three kingdoms
dialing back the larger than life
legends and giving mighty heroes
retinues of bodyguards the second being
the truth behind the myth where heroes
remain single powerful entities and gods
provided passive buffs with access to
unique interpretations to mythic units
and access to unique interpretations to
mythic units like the minotaur being a
single mighty man wearing the skull of a
bull and thirdly a mythological mode
where legends and myths were more
fleshed out and represented as written
in the iliad heroes grow in power gods
can take more active parts in battles
with poseidon summoning waves against
your enemies the minotaur now being a
legitimate half man half bull and giving
players the ability to bring units like
the fierce and cerberus into their ranks
personally i find the way total war is
experimenting with history and fiction
like they've done with troy and three
kingdoms fascinating and i hope it's one
they continue to toy with originally the
game was a one year epic story exclusive
and was actually a free download as long
as you redeemed it within the first 24
hours of release which caused a surge of
7.5 million copies to be claimed within
a single day
that brings us to the franchise's newest
release and the final entry in the
warhammer trilogy total war warhammer 3.
the focal point of the world is set to
the northern and eastern elements of
warhammer's old world and builds on some
of the more unique factions and
civilizations of the fiction human
factions like kislev and grand cafe were
built in much the same way that the
vampire coasts were in total world war
hammer 2. kislev have very few models to
base designs off of in the case of
cathay there are none at all so instead
creative assembly once again had to draw
inspiration from warhammer's law stories
and these factions real-world
inspirations of medieval russia and
imperial china to help fully realize
these factions in a way that would fit
in the world of total war warhammer and
while there are also the yoga kingdoms
to balance out the roster the focus of
this game is very much the realms of
chaos and demons each chaos god has been
fleshed out to become their own faction
with core nurgle zinc and slaanesh all
having armies of demons led by greater
demons and cultists and each infecting
the world in a different way these
demons can also culminate under one
demon prince allowing players to mix and
match units from different chaotic
factions as one force as the player
fights to earn favor from each chaos god
allowing for different units as well as
a fully customizable faction leader
meaning players can throw on different
wings limbs and adornments depending on
how heavy their worship the campaign map
is also twice the size of that from the
eye of the vortex campaign in total war
warhammer 2. and for the first time
allows players to venture into the
realms of chaos themselves with new
challenges and gameplay elements
appearing in each hellish realm with all
the variety that comes with fully
realizing factions like kislev as well
as featuring some of the more esoteric
ones like nurgle and yoga kingdoms the
game offers some of the franchise's most
diverse flavors and ways to play and
while i'm writing this before the
release of the game we can be confident
this will only grow as the grand
campaign is introduced and more and more
content is brought in through the life
of total war warhammer 3. what's next
for the franchise though is yet to be
seen could creative assembly take on
warhammer's age of sigmar or a new
fictional universe entirely perhaps
they'll revisit medieval with a third
entry into the time period or explore a
new saga altogether only time will tell
but after 22 years 15 main games and a
handful of spin-offs thousands of years
of history covered a 30-year franchise
at their back and nearly every strategy
game player keeping their eyes on them
the history of total war has been a hell
of a lot brighter than the real world
history that they've pulled inspiration
from thanks for watching my history of
the total war franchise a series that
i've adored since i was able to work a
mouse if you want to check out some more
awesome history documentaries we have a
bunch on the channel so be sure to
subscribe for more videos like this and
of course like the video if you enjoyed
it until next time thanks again for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one
you